think it should be 50 50 custody like
off the bat I don't know why women are
like even if the man doesn't want 50 50
the child would have to live with the
Fonda 50. well I mean if he doesn't want
to be in the life I guess not no he
wants let's say but he doesn't want the
child staying like four days he wants
like one day I think off the back it's
just I think off the bat they should
start with 50 50 custody and they can
work it out between them right like the
government should say you both have to
yeah like 50. that makes sense yeah
because I don't know why women are just
assumed to be better parents when
they're more likely to abuse a child
they're more violent towards their
children
yeah what have you seen
um so
you can go to supermarkets you can hear
them I'm shot at the child
um I had
um I had a couple on these I would like
that and it's like I've even got some
friends that were like that and I know a
couple of times I've been like
why are you shining like that so much
sometimes obviously it's not as much
prevalent as it is now back in the day
it was a little beating as well but the
way I grew up all my friends me the dad
is the one you know shouting or beating
or you know the mom is not the one but
that's that's the first difference in
comparison but could it could it be that
it's because the moms are around the
kids more yes because you know when you
are around a child or more they
frustrate you more yeah like if you're
just coming like if you're even not in
the picture or uh if you are but like
you work long hours and you only see
your children for like a little short
time if the mom is with them like pretty
much 24 7 they're gonna drive her crazy
I think I'm gonna disagree on that one I
think women are just more emotional true
yes like like you know women are more
likely to wage war
to wage war
like percentage-wide like I know more
men have because more men have been in
power but women are actually more likely
to do it when they're in power
what's wage war like Star War oh go to
war
um like go to find but yeah just I think
like I just think we get pissed off I've
seen a lot of women trying to fight men
thinking what are you doing so yeah
because even in my household I love you
I lived with both parents and
if I compare the two my mom did way more
shine than what I did like he knew ways
to con not say control us but to keep us
obedient
that did beaten
as in the early early stages yes but
even then
he didn't really need to be as much we
weren't that bad as children but at the
same time it was like if he needed to
raise his voice it was situational
where my mom was shot constant that was
like
my mom used to hit me with a spoon
don't get me wrong for like uh single
mothers it's not it's not easy bringing
up a child or kids on your own it's
tough you know I applaud them for what
they do but when you start getting angry
and you know you're screaming at your
kid and there's veins coming down your
neck you know that's you just um that's
just way too much too much anger for a
child that doesn't understand what you
do the only thing they can get from that
is trauma but there's you know in all
the situations ninety percent of women
are looking at the parents to the child
there's only 10 of full-time single
dance that look after the child as the
main parent just ten percent so I feel
like that doesn't government
prioritizing women yeah yeah it could be
but I feel like men don't know how it is
like to have a child almost 24 7. that's
because
single appearance single fathers raise
better children exactly than single
mothers when they have been given the
chance they've done a better job yeah I
just think women like we get frustrated
like when there's a problem yeah yeah we
just get frustrated and like cry or get
mad yeah I feel and I do it too like
like even even and I kind of noticed the
differences in like the genders doing
like solving problems because even with
like my business like I'll be doing
stuff and I'll just be like get mad at
something and my brothers will be like
okay why don't you try this this this
this like they're just more logical do
you think a man would do a better job
raising a girl than than a woman
yeah
yeah right what about the feminine side
um would she be more masculine then
probably
um I would say like she's probably she'd
probably be a tomboy
it might be hard to find a man my mom
was raised by my granddad so my mum was
had four siblings she's the youngest my
grand my mom my nan ran off different
life then my granddad raised worked has
his own business and raised four kids my
mum it was a single mom
I'm not
blowing it while I'm playing with a
trumpet because she's the best mum
raised my brother me and my sister
strong woman was the breadwinner was
everything The Decorator everything well
she's shouting a lot all the time but
she did it because we were bad kids
she was a young mum she had my brother
at 15 me at 17.
but that she got I feel like she got
that strongness from my Grandad because
he was a very strict
working man did everything he played
both roles so I just think it
it differs whereas she was raised by a
man I was raised by a woman so I feel
like I've got both why uh I actually
like this idea that like men raised
children better I would believe that
because they're more logic why more men
is it because of the government because
I feel like a lot of men wouldn't want
100 custody of the child oh no they will
um they want their freedom too no no I
think most men want to be in their kids
lives um I can't remember what the stat
is off the top of my head but one of the
most likely times that a guy is going to
commit suicide is when it's like
post-divorce because oftentimes she'll
take care of the divorce yeah what about
men who not like in marriage-wise yeah
but let's say men who who been in a
relation there's no marriage they just
aren't a child with someone who they
actually 100 because because I feel like
they're very happy with 50 or less
um are you talking about men when
there's no marriage it's just with a
woman
I don't I don't know but like in my
experience most men want to be with
their children even even if it's in a
shitty situation for the most 100 unless
they're like one of those guys that are
just you know shooting up and everybody
but that's not the majority well I don't
think most men are going to want a
hundred percent because if you're in if
you're alive and in the child's life why
would you 100 you'd rather do 50 50.
because at the end of the day even the
stats say that being a better fathers
there's a certain element to a child
that a man can't give that's what a
woman needs to be around so being 100 to
your child is not as fully beneficial as
it would be having both so say for me me
for example as a man even though I may
want 50 I'm not going to 100 because
there's certain errors I can't give you
I can't tell you what it's like to be a
woman in this world do nothing like a
lot of men are happy to see the child
twice a week and they don't want 50 50.
that's probably because they have to
rather than because I've seen guys and
they they they're happy with their like
yeah two days a week every other week
yeah it's not like it's banned
everything one business a month they're
happy they're happy to you know live
their life and
but then was that yeah is that a father
that was actually heavily invested in
that woman before they had a child no if
that was a if that was an unplanned
pregnancy yeah
there I I think both of them were
unplanned yes yes heavily invested and
I'm pretty sure two days might not be
enough
in his mind but you have to settle for
it no I I know someone then asking for
someone or I know two other people
all right fair enough
but I'm just saying I personally do know
of people and me myself also I was
raised like that every other weekend so
there's people out here that just they
just don't want more responsibility with
their children yeah I don't see men
really wanting unless there was marriage
or something but wanting 50 50 I think
they're happy for the Saturday Sunday or
just Saturday I don't know I I think
most men want have
I think most men want their kids to turn
out better and most men want to be a
part of that in general
um I I think sometimes maybe there are
cases where women kind of trap a man and
like the men are kind of resentful
because like they don't they didn't want
this kid to begin with and she kind of
knew what she was doing yeah would you
say that's true yeah
yeah no yeah I agree as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible